pour ceux qui auraient loupé l'épisode
d'hier vous a fait un petit bilan des
moments les plus forts de l'émission
d'abord on va revenir sur l'épisode hier
après on va revenir sur claude et ça je
sais que vous l'attendez tout cette
affaire on aura des témoignages
commencent avec la nouveauté cette année
lille débat disney ou matthieu delormeau
il rappe très prochaine
une fois que les candidats sont éliminés
ils ont droit à une deuxième chance pour
appel à ces dernières c'est quand mu qui
s'était fait éliminer on voit donc quand
dix arrivées sur l'île des bannis elle a
le droit à une deuxième chance avec une
nouvelle épreuve mais ça s'est pas passé
comme prévu regardez to watch j'ai la
chance d'avoir une deuxième chance mon
but c'est d'aller le plus loin possible
je me dis que rien n'est perdu et que je
s'il faut sortir les crocs pour pouvoir
atteindre nos objectifs que je le ferai
bonjour à tous les trois
les deux premiers qui arrive à monter un
édifice composé de cinq ans reparte sur
ligne des bannis
clémentine vous restez dans la devanture
candice malheureusement c'est terminé au
revoir qu'en dise la jeune mais
volontaire petite championne est déçu
pour mon but c'est d'aller le plus loin
possible
alors va revenir sur l'épisode d'hier et
dans un instant
charlotte c'était dans l'île des héros
2020 va réagir avec nous on va nous dire
tout ce qui se passe sur claude ella est
l état des côtes dans la voiture de
qu'elle va nous donner son témoignage
merci charlotte d'être là ça va
charlotte
ça va alors on se tutoie
ses tarifs bah ouais bah montant région
vas-y façon que ça marche mais pour moi
pour vous
et il ya même mon ami bien sûr et vous
êtes tous les jours au téléphone tu dois
fleuve sava match aller ça va tu es
content de te voir tu sais que ça
d'habitude mohamed que j'aime et qui est
un m voilà je le dis c'est il sait que
je laime fort mes chéris hier donc koh
lanta 4 millions de téléspectateurs et
surtout on va revenir dans un instant
sur caudin parce que c'est vrai que
comme moi je suis fan absolu de clown et
on va voir ce qui se passe en ce moment
c'est vrai que j'entends les pires
atrocités gênant mais j'ai l'impression
d'être avec des proches de mathieu
alors koh lanta ça marche pas mal mais
ça remonte un petit peu mais c'est pas
encore les audiences d'avant c'est un
truc de fou ça n'est remonté que parce
qu'alex hugo était un épisode en
rediffusion très franchement parce que
hier il ya eu l'île des bannis vous
l'avez montré après ça traîne en
longueur et effectivement vous avez bien
perçu le noeud c'est claude
lagrée ses enfants allaient tout à
l'heure c'est très utile à natick
épreuve des radeaux c'était une épreuve
de confort le but est simple les
candidats doivent construire leur propre
et comme d'habitude leur propre au
radeau les qualités candidats étaient
comme des oufs mois et donc c'est
vraiment des comptes vous demande de
construire un radeau qui saurait le
faire ici oui mais vous savez contrario
la raddho
à
l'aide des bambous et des cordes que
vous trouverez sur votre ils
construisent et les meilleurs radeau
pour voguer vers la victoire
jugement même si l'on considère à dos
c'est une des épisodes que que
j'affectionne le plus sur koh lanta
l'idée c'est d'essayer une embarcation
qui cote plus fixe le plus légères leur
avouer top suis très confiant on a un
peu les fesses dans l'eau mais ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'ils ont dû faire comme d'habitude la
course pour ça ça c'est des épreuves on
connaît normalement tu révises un schéma
bien sûr dans ta baignoire du phare à
detroit
vous parlez de cette course avec vos
radios que vous allez disputer d'abord
la récompense
attention les gones à la broche
derniers symboles à détruire à l'aide de
l'adie sain avec un bal sur cette année
l'histoire des jeux
venez récupérer votre récompense
je
allez bon retour au bon appétit
alors on a un petit rigolo de vous
montrer on a on va on va se revoir la
récompense de l'épreuve de confort
regarder et se sont mis vraiment bien
[Musique]
alors moi je le vois bien la maison s'il
n'y a pas le choix il n'y a pas le choix
aux gagner les pochoirs l'autre je vous
ai entendu dire quand vous l'avez
découvert mais il est normal et non
sarko
alors donc aidé alors moi ce que
j'attends donc on a passé les épreuves
et je trouve qu'il y en ait c'était trop
long franchement ça arrive trop tard les
épreuves là c'est une tannée et
réguillon et puis il ya trop d'histoires
je voudrais que le problème de koh lanta
c'est si on n'est pas un fan de
l'émission qu'on regarde pas chaque
semaine on comprend rien il ya des
histoires ya des camps et des
réunifications et des nouvelles idées
nouvelles règles je trouve qu'ils
devraient se se baser aux règles simples
de l'émission c'est à dire les
aventuriers sur une île déserte avec des
épreuves c'est ça qu'on veut voir c'est
les épreuves de koh lanta merci à tous
un succès très belle année justement les
épaules les épreuves ont ensuite fait
leur épreuve d'immunité l'équipe des
rouges ont gagné mais pas mais par
contre n'a mahdia n'a pas tenu le choc
vous l'avez vu ça ou pas oui oui
regarder koh lanta hier ça pour les
messieurs vous êtes les deux qui plaît
moi je voulais c'est vrai mais vous
couchez jamais moi c'est une de mes
passions regarde je croyais dormir la
gym en même temps ben comme insiste
important
panier 3 bis c'est l'équipe qui aura la
dernière un panier en l'air qui évitera
le conseil le nomma bien trois clients
pour füle
bah trois clients supplémentaires paulo
[Musique]
j'aime aller retour copé oui tout à fait
l'allemagne a du mal et souffler épuisé
mais il repart la mania est tabou france
le géant mais un genou à terre
la mania très fatigué et prise en charge
par le médecin de l'aventuré
et enfin est venu le temps du conseil ou
fait le résumé est commun à sam a fait
ce ont failli aux actes et ira il adore
mais c'est vrai qu'ils sont ok defour
ouf il s'est très vite fait calmé par
coumba regarder on avait une candidate
se faire éliminer hier c'est écolo ce
que je suis venu ici pour pour essayer
de ressembler à un theora et je me rends
compte que chaque jour en fait je m'en
éloigne de plus en plus ça c'est une
grosse erreur on est chaque personne est
différente en fait on a tous une
personnalité différente mais la pression
pour rien parce que tu peux pas
ressembler à t auras tu n'es pas
toujours faut que tu acceptes sûr non
mais ça c'est le premier truc il faut
que tu acceptes tu me disent tu cherches
pas lui ressembler tu as ta personnalité
tu es sam était brasse et au grain
voilà vous avez tous voté je vais
chercher leur nez je procède au
dépouillement clément clément clément
clémence les aventuriers d'attributs
jeunes ont décidé de vous éliminer et
leur sentence est irrévocable
soyez bons soyez forts et puis quoi
qu'il arrive n'oubliez pas que la vie
tout entière est une aventure merci
clémence
se tient à marquer l'épisode d'hier ici
la sphère claude manipulation cobayes
arrogance comprenez vous les critiques
contre claude de koh lanta ça a été en
top tweets toute la journée alors on va
revenir à la première de claude claude
c'est le plus grand champion de kolontar
maintenance égrenant celles à
la tête des gens 19
s'est arrêté le
bcsa ces matches il n'a pas gagné c'est
des questions de voilà il s'est fait
éliminer mais dans les épreuves c'est le
plus fort c'est luc à leurs codes à
leurs encore de toutes les épreuves
c'est le sait vraiment aventuré hors
pair alors c'est sa première c'était en
2005 on va revenir donc sur le parcours
de coûts dans sa province en 2010 que j
en 2005 qui n'étaient pas nés en 2010
dans koh lanta vietnam il est encore
inconnu du grand public regardez à 30
ans ce jeune chauffeur de m et quelqu'un
sur qui l'on peut compter même si lui ne
compte sur personne pour réussir sa vie
ce faire ne rien devoir à personne
tous les aventuriers ont sauté mais
alain n'est pas bien il est au bord de
la noyade heureusement claude intervient
claude a atteint la structure il doit
allumer son flambeau en le plongeant
dans la vasque de
[Applaudissements]
la côte c'est aussi comme vous l'avez
dit 19 victoires sur des épreuves
individuelles sur toutes ses
participations c'est celui qui a gagné
le plus d'épreuves c'est vraiment un
grand champion klaus et le champion de
koh lanta regarde
et la victoire est pour vous les ouvrez
ce totem il est pour vous l'équipe des
rouges et claude l'architecte naval en
chef c'est à vous que j'ai envie de
lorraine
sebroko il continuer l'aventuré koh
lanta bravo
[Musique]
la victoire pour que
reste un obstacle à claude pour
l'emporter c'est le troisième parcours
du combattant que vous gagnez dans votre
histoire sur koh lanta gfr
pour les choses et pourquoi rendez vous
compte le record que d'être né claude
depuis 2012 était de 3 heures et 11
minutes vous l'avez portée claude à 3
heures et 47 minutes
c'est un candidat qui force le respect
on va recevoir une séquence qui avait
beaucoup marqué les esprits les
téléspectateurs à seconde année on y
voit qu de remettre la candidate inès à
sa place elle avait dit la veille que
les derniers étaient les moins méritants
je vous laisse découvrir s'il a répondu
le lendemain et chérie coco donc c'était
l'exemple de ton sourire
c'est bon pour inès
avec l autre vous est arrivé à la
dernière fois où tu vas prendre tous les
sacs désolé
parce que c'est juste lui ou ses
segmentés tendu dit non je te donne pas
les cinq jeux suivants thilleman a
l'immunité ce que tu reviens sur ça
est-ce que dernier sera éliminé j'en
sais rien donné samedi donnent les sacs
jaunes nous a posé une question tout à
l'heure est-ce que lors du prochain
conseil vous voterez au mérite comme
vous l'avait prôné hier non ça sera plus
et ça me fait plaisir que le dise et si
je peux me permettre des tribus un sac à
dos 3 ce soit vraiment une course
équitable et une belle bataille finale
pour l'e3 c'est je pense la chose la
plus longue étape qu'on puisse faire
évidemment vous pouvez enfin c'est vrai
qu' il était irréprochable en jeu dans
koh lanta et hier on va vous montrer les
interventions clos d'hier soir et son
comportement a été jugée arrogante
donneur de leçon hier soir ça a été
fermement sur les réseaux sociaux il a
42 ans il est chauffeur de maître claude
j'ai la chance de rencontrer je vous en
parlais dans un instant mais c'est vrai
que hier ça a été un truc de fou ça
continue aujourd'hui il est en top twin
tard garde pour moi c'est pas la bonne
solution d'avoir cette grande traverse
on ne peut pas la mettre comme ça
je n'ai que 3 3
je connais pas cette fois sont attachés
comment tu fais pour attaquer devant
vous ressemble c'était une idée d'un
chef
mais après pour un retour et on a
voulu retourner à propos le porter à
l'automne dans l'eau segura
c'est très long
donc c'est pas possible tu vas attaché
commentaires et on arrête avec tes
conneries aussi sur scène d'émotion aux
radios si moi je fais pas ne vous laisse
faire enfin son goût c'est le fait un
coup de baguette coup le ring alors on
fait comme vous voulez merci combat
c'est bon la saison
enfin
les ignore si vous voulez j'ai fait
voilà ça va alors à ce moment ça va un
moment quand on a fait un effort comme
sur une info aujourd'hui mais qu'on veut
pas les péchés soir il faut combler
c'est toi ça va quoi et depuis l'épisode
d'hier donc c'est un déferlement 1
contre claude est ce que vous comprenez
les téléspectateurs qui sont en colère
contre lui on va voir charlotte qui va
nous parler de claude puisque vous étiez
avec lui avant 2020 sur l'île de hierro
et alors mohamed paraît que c'est un
grand pote après un club c'est un bon
pote est bon on prend la scripte tous
qui sinon on peut on peut comprendre des
fois parce que c'est ça peut être aussi
un défaut de montage parce qu'on sait on
connaît la nature humaine et peut-être
des fois débordante comme ça comme on le
voit à l'écran mais claude il n'est pas
ce qu'on dit sur les réseaux sociaux etc
c'est un fin stratège c'est vrai c'est
un grand champion de kolontar le sait
aussi mais tous ces déferlements sur
cool je ne comprends pas je ne
comprendrais jamais d'ailleurs surtout
les candidats parce que ça comme un jeu
et aujourd'hui voilà une estime
aujourd'hui il en prend plein la gueule
l'oise
charlotte toi tu étais dans l'aventuré
avec lui est ce que tu es d'accord avec
ce qui s'est dit qu'aucun a été jugé
arrogant et manipulateur ou pas du tout
alors déjà là on voit à claude enfin
quand on parle de claude puel début de
l'émission là en l'occurrence et sur les
épreuves et il est très fort et c'est
alors oui ça on peut pas lui enlever
c'est comme quand on dit il faut séparer
l'artiste de l'humain et ben là c'est un
peu pareil on enlève l'on sépare le
performeur de l'humain c'est un petit
peu ça donc toutes ces images sur les
performances de claude ok stop claude
c'est un champion très fort en épreuve
ça ok on l'enlève à côté de ça il ya
l'humain il ya la personne qu'il est et
ouest est un manipulateur c'est en fin
stratège
en effet c'est c'est quelqu'un qui peut
être arrogant
et lors de ma saison il a été mon l'a
pas forcément vu donc on a vu le claude
lice le cloud très forts etc et mais en
2010 2011 enfin moi je regardais pas à
cette époque là mais il était déjà comme
ça donc en fait je comprends pas
pourquoi aujourd'hui les gens sont
étonnés de sa réalité comment il a
toujours été comme en bas comme ces
manipulateurs arrogant et dirais que
factuelles bas bien sûr il m'a rabaisser
déjà en tant que femme ça soit
physiquement sur mon corps à me dire
mais n'était pas sportif toi mais je
comprends pas mais attends mais c'est
tout mais non mais il ya des blagues il
ya rabaisser la femme en tant que tel
devant tout le monde et rigoler et même
lorsque j'étais plus dans le jeu ça
rigolait encore sur sur sa sur le corps
jean mach un
film mais ça c'était pas à filmer mais
tu crois que la preuve elle va le
montrer pas non à peut-être qu'après on
sait qu a annoncé que la prod des fois
que un peu montré des choses qui qui
sont à dérangeante au 6 mai mais de la
deûle à être aussi ou si je pense aussi
macho et aussi je sais pas c'est pas
l'image de claude que j'aimerais c'est
pas c'est pas tout l'image qu'on a de
claude après en tant que candidat c'est
vrai qu'on peut être victime d'un d'un
d'un leader comme ça mais je peux
comprendre aussi l'attitude de charlotte
et son et sa frustration au mal super
frustré du tout de mon aventure c'est
simplement je raconte ce que j'ai vécu
et mon expérience avec claude mais comme
j'ai eu ça et comme la démo non on
rigolait énormément ensemble mais voilà
une personne n'est pas que comme ça elle
n'est pas que manipulatrice que arrogant
c'est un tout mais en effet il l'est
sapho faut le dire c'est vrai il est
comme ça alors enfin revenir sur cherche
d'autres instants mais guillaume bas
quand on voit les images choc on a
l'impression que claude il a pris la
grosse tête et en fait ce tarif chez les
candidats de koh lanta c'est une très
bonne idée pour l'audience mais je pense
pas que ce soit une bonne idée pour les
candidats parce que vous avez des gens
normaux qui ont une vie normale on l'a
dit claude il est chauffeur de maître
qui du jour au lendemain se retrouve
avec une énorme exposition médiatique
vous avez quand même 6 7 millions de
personnes qui vous regardent chaque
semaine sur plusieurs saisons et qui
viennent aussi beaucoup d'argent ils
sont pas beaucoup payé sur koh lanta
mais claude c'est devenu une star il
travaillait beaucoup de marques donc
notoriété plus argens et les ingrédients
idéaux pour pété les plombs et je pense
qu'on dirait en tout cas en gardant un
avantage qu'il a pris la grosse tête
gagner très bien fait avant moi j'ai la
gagner encore plus d'argent la wii avec
les marques oui on va leur est pas du
tout d'accord avec toi guillon parce
qu'en fait là on le voit effectivement
il est peut-être un peu peur c'est qu'un
peu arrogant mais encore une fois c'est
un spécialiste il est c'est grâce à lui
qu'ils gagnent l'épreuve les jaunes et
qui donc ils ont l'épreuve de confort
donne des conseils et donc qui donne des
conseils et de la même manière qu il
explique comment on fait des noeuds
parce que les autres sont incapables sa
mère des enfants et donc c'est normal
que ce soit un leader et on attend ça
lui dans le radeau il l'a fait deux fois
il l'a fait dans ma saison et avant dont
il est le champion
moi j'ai entendu malgré tout qu'elle
était et ça je rejoins un petit peu ce
que ce que vous disiez charlotte qu'il
était quand même un tout petit peu dans
le storytelling en tout cas à ranger et
chouchouté par la prod et il ferait et
c'est là où peut-être qu'il un peu
manipulateur des pactes avant le
tournage avec certains candidats comme
par exemple avec le moment où avec le
monde se sent mais là c'est le casting
de
consigne à tous ses copains oui claude
aurait fait son casting à tous ses
copains donc forcément c'est ennuyant
même à gagner ce que je ne sais déjà
alors par rapport à cette saison là et
ce qui se passe c'est que claude il est
trés mis en avant le voit énormément
c'est normal c'est long c'est le plus
grand champion et ce qui s'est passé
c'est que la production a été un peu
déçu de certains autres candidats
notamment comme sam qui est très absent
alors que sur l'édition précédente où il
était on le voyait tout le temps donc du
coup on voit énormément claude parce que
c'est le seul qui a vraiment joué le jeu
et maintenant si vous voulez bien je
peux répondre à charlotte ne furent que
cha cha ou alors charlotte je suis pas
étonné par votre témoignage je vais
essayer d'expliquer ou non les
spectateurs ce qui se passe vous faites
partie d'un clan de quelques personnes
de quelques anciens de candidats de koh
lanta qui en veulent énormément
énormément à claude ils sont armés
mentalement par pascal vous êtes très
proche de pascal je pense même qu avant
l'émission de pascale il est venu chez
moi
je vous dis pas tout cas pascal même pas
du tout claude on est que et que charles
là et que charlotte elle n'osait même
pas que j'aime en lice démolissent sur
les réseaux sociaux en interne avec
d'autres candidats claude en permanence
donc je pense que le témoignage de
charlotte je vous respecte infiniment
est très orientée et que vous êtes
manipulés madame
je suis manipulé par personne parce
qu'elle ne sait même pas que je suis ici
je n'ai même pas échanger avec lui
j'aurais pu l'appeler parce qu'il est
déjà venu ici alors c'est comment ma
première fois j'ai justement j'ai voulu
y aller comme moi j'avais envie de venir
oui et sans être manipulé par personne
et vous parlez très souvent des choses
que vous ne connaissez pas quand
jack o'lantern je vous le connaissez
je comprends pas comment on peut dire
des choses qu'on dont on fait un pas
vers les réseaux sociaux vous animez
beaucoup contre claude excusez-moi
contre club havrais pas de lui j'ai
parlé une fois de lui pendant mon m m'a
diffusion sur les raisons qui ont parlé
souvent bénin nicéphore qui pak alors
qu'elle est organisée à l'envoyer dire
ça ressort témoins qu'à une chose où je
parle de de claude aujourd'hui elle
recherche évasion et dernier que j'ai
pas dis quelque chose sur chloé beaucoup
de témoignages d'anciens candidats
[Applaudissements]
cyril j'allais ballon fait non mais tous
genres et dans les tout prochains mois
tu as des gars de koh lanta qui
n'empêchait donc
irait là non mais dis non mais c'est
bien sûr dans koh lanta bien sûr je ne
vais pas donner les noms je respecte mes
sources alors c'est l'excellent
satisfait beaucoup de monde hier ce qui
s'est passé sur les réseaux sociaux oui
j'adore claude vachon j'ai déjà
rencontré plusieurs fois en apparaissant
parfois ça c'est un amoureux mais qu'on
a on a aggravé les ondes on doit faire
dire des trucs ensemble mais il s'est
très vite imposé comme le chouchou des
médias on l'a vu répondre aux interviews
vous l'avez dit c'est vrai que c'est
devenu le métro une énorme star c'est
devenu vraiment rappelle la voilà c'est
gavé des coûts d'achat claude toutes les
semaines c'était vraiment l'homme idéal
l'exemple regardez
claude est avec nous donc claude jeu
mais la révélation de koh lanta c'était
donc ton troisième koh lanta plateau ce
mot c'est claude prix chauffeur de
maître g 42 ans et puis me découvrir
dans l'émission d' aventure koh lanta
pas passer à la 3g pas prendre de risque
bonjour claude merci d'être avec nous
koh-lanta l'île des héros ce soir
deuxième épisode
comment vous êtes arrivé dans cette
aventure par le plus grand des hasards
en fait
les deux indes au cas où pas de joker
[Musique]
on
dit même que si denis demain arrêter
l'émission c'est peut-être kloten
reprendrait les relations exactes c'est
vrai c'est ce qu'on dit et on parle
aussi il ya une rumeur qu'il ans et je
le dis tu impact à 4 way of life chacun
25 euros qu'est ce que c'est que cette
histoire dans koh lanta
dont beaucoup cet honneur c'est quoi
cette histoire nous ça existe et il l'a
fait on dit quoi si on en sort quinze
mois ouais en 2005 on l'a fait clémence
on l'a fait avec combat arrive ça arrive
à fait nous on l'a fait on savait que on
savait qu'on allait arriver à plusieurs
en finale elle voulait pas qu'un etien
qui prennent le gain marche du coup on
l'a partagée à 5 vous avez guide est
avantagé 110000 euros cent dix mille
euros dont la date a pris une petite
j'ai pris un petit bain chimique je vous
dis non non non c'est fou ça laisse
avait donc là il paraît qu'il ya aussi
dur à dinan oui mais moi j'ai entendu ça
par rapport à que cette année là enfin
cette année c'est à dire qu'il aurait
fait un pacte aussi avec chine avec
laurent et avec une autre une autre
aventure hier moi je suis assez étonné
parce que la production vient nous voir
le produit tard vient nous voir en nous
menaçant si vous faites ça vous verrez
plus jamais vous referai koh lanta donc
de la jeune formation
certains cas aujourd'hui clément cela
fait douze saisons je comprends pas à 16
ans on l'a fait mais c'est vrai que
c'est bizarre ça décrédibilise et
aventure comme à
l'étranger
ouais non non c'est vrai c'est un côté
solidaire on n'a qu'à 110 milles euros à
partager on se dit allez on est cinq on
va se partager ses 1 3 non seulement ça
décrédibilise pas mais de toute façon
c'est ça prouve la force du jeu de
montrer ce que ça fait tellement parlé
cela dit la violence des réseaux sociaux
est absolument odieuses comme dans les
zones occupées mais ont en revanche
claude moi qui regarde attentivement il
ya quelque chose effectivement c'est une
créature qu'on a contribué à façonner et
quelque part il est un tout petit peu
moins naturel à la marge il est un tout
petit peu plus poseurs à la main
en fait alors est-ce que ça
décrédibilise complètement cette
stratégie sous-jacente le téléspectateur
ne le sait pas mais tu paies en fait
complet de mon peuple il va pas
comprendre de ce qui va se passer donc
évidemment que ça déplaît aussi ça vous
choque que cet arrangement est alors
apparemment il l'a dit un mot c'est vrai
que ce n'était pas la première fois que
je fais il ya dès qu'il ya des candidats
qui arrive au début des deux candidats
de koh lanta les aventuriers qui se dit
voilà on est à 4 on se dit voilà si on
gagne les cent mille euros ont fait 25
chalets contre tessier la rumeur on m a
joliment trop tard il y en a quatre qui
gagnent et bon partage ak oui moi c'est
comme ça ça vous choque bout bah oui
parce que par exemple quand on arrive au
bout l épreuve des poteaux etc on se dit
non vous voient en vous regardez on se
dit tout le coeur qui met l'ania qui met
pas ce qu'ils veulent est justement
celui qui est si on se dit que bah
finalement et tu sais quoi c'est pas
très grave mais arrivent deuxièmes
troisièmes parce que on est à 4 donc
quoi qu'il arrive on va diviser par 4
simulation d'un coup nous on se dit ah
bah mince alors quand engagements qu'on
croyait à 2000% il est pas si à demi mot
que l'on pensait pas que l'oseille
regrette qu'ils ne compta c'est vraiment
charlotte chez l'aventuré mathieu ne
leur a jamais
commenter ces cent mille euros c'est
vrai c'est pas cher gagner parce qu'on
pense que
par rapport à d'autres jeux on voit
gagner c'est un gagnent des sommes
astronomiques 20 millions d'euros il
restait deux cents ans
c'est franchement cent mille euros pour
koh lanta c'est pas cher gagner et on ne
le fait pas pour les locaux n'ont pas
franchement je suis pas pour ne pas
avoir de stratégie qu'on vient de sortir
la wii vous bah oui le fait que des
candidats impose de même des règles qui
sont pas les règles de l'émission ça
contribue à cette idée qu'il ya certains
candidats qui se prennent un peu pour
les boss de l'émission et c'est la
vérité il ya un rapport de force qui
s'est inversée claudie c'est que c'est
une star il sait qu'il fait de
l'audience à chaque fois qu'il va dans
une émission et je l'attends ça cartonne
et donc voilà que le dit charlotte
j'adore et la vérité c'est
qu'aujourd'hui surkiffe de lui je
l'adoré sur les épreuves
et la vérité c'est qu'aujourd'hui les
candidats star des émissions c'était
vrai sur les 12 coups de midi avec
christian quesada l'époque c'est vrai
sur les télé réalité est là c'est vrai
avec l'autre c'est eux qui font la loi
sur les tournages et c'est pas normal
c'est la prod qui devrait maîtriser le
journal est là lui clairement on voit
qu'il est en train de faire la loi c'est
pas normal prévaudra cerexhe
cdh microsociété bien sûr une
microsociété il ya un leader il ya des
suiveurs ya des gens qui sont brillants
il ya des gens qui le sont moins et en
train de voir ça justement toutes les
stratégies c'est ce que tu vois dans la
vraie vie non tout simplement oui j'ai
l'impression qu'on regarde et encore
moins d'accord mais vraiment énorme en
chocolat beaucoup plus d'ampleur c'est à
dire que aujourd'hui pourquoi il ya des
suiveurs parce que tout simplement les
autres candidats ont peur de la vie et
du public on perd des téléspectateurs
sur les réseaux sociaux doit alors de ma
saison on en a pris vraiment gêné reçus
sans et pourquoi pas on sait que claude
est aimé alors faut être avec claude
parce que si on est contre lyon va
prendre cher donc est-ce que tu oses
est-ce que tu j'oserais voté contre il
n'y avait que moi il n'y avait que moi
dans ma saison qui a été contre l'unique
scène free avait vu dans son jeu et
c'est pour ça qu'il a été très dure avec
moi et d'ailleurs à la fin du jeu il est
venu voir et s'est excusé en disant
rester très dur et avec toi mais bon tu
tu avais vu clair dans mon jeu donc en
route était un danger qui était trop
grand pour moi une homélie verte oui
mais là je vais répondre à guillaume
c'est dégueulasse que vous faites dire
vous êtes en train de présenter que
l'autre comme un chef mafieux qaïda
badge c'est ce que vous avez dit avant
les inégalités et lanta a dit réjean
très le jeu qui ferait tourner le jeu
autour de lui excusez moi claude claude
il a été parfaitement honnête c'est un
des seuls qui n'est pas hypocrite il dit
la même chose quand il est filmé et
quand il n'est pas animé puisque c'est
quelqu'un annoncer qu'il se passe à ce
jour d algérie c'est quelqu'un qui joue
les jeux de polenta et vous vous le
présenter comme quelqu'un qui décide de
n'est pas du tout en un sens je dis qu'à
m'hamdi petite info on me dit qu'ils
mettent claude en avant mais oui la
prenait goût il va y avoir un problème
par équipes avec une autre légende du
oui non peut pas dire qu'il me paraît
qu'il va y avoir un problème dans les
magnifiques attention on va pas le dire
voilà il paraît voilà on a ici c'est
comme ça nous avons un gros problème
c'est ce qu'on me dit c'est avec un
autre candidat les banques se pourrait
qu'ils mettent claude forcément
énormément d'avancé que c'est la star du
jeu de blizzard là ils lui rendent pas
service sur le montage suis désolé de
claude que j'adore et là il en prend
plein la gueule oui je dis passagers dit
qu'avant la star de koh lanta c'était le
concept et le format de l'émission et
que les candidats étaient là pour y
participer aujourd'hui la star de koh
lanta c'est claude donc c'est lui qui
fait la loi comme on
sait très bien qui fait de l'audience il
sait très bien
que si les gens là et brillant et c'est
comme ça dans la vie voilà on est tous
en même temps ou en tant que
téléspectatrice mathieu moi je suis
trompé en fait je serai occupé parce que
si geste si par exemple claude a fait un
pacte crée effectivement avec laurent et
je ne le sais pas avec theora et je ne
sais pas avec filet je ne sais pas mon
prend pour une gogo en fait je mets dans
le programme on en a des milliers
avant de partir les candidats ils savent
qui part qui est casté donc forcément se
passe des coups de fil entre eux enfin
voila moi je pars alors on se met
ensemble et c'est un triste connaissent
tous se connaissent tous ça c'est pas un
secret on le sait tous contre nous les
candidats c'est ça le problème est un
problème d
après avec les anonymes ils n'ont pas ce
souci parce qu'ils se connaissent pas
ils assurent aujourd'hui après avec la
star tout le monde se connaît moi je
pars toi tu pars et ses avions fait une
alliance alors déshabillé ce que tu nous
as dit alors que toi tu avais partager
donc c'est clémence qu'avec guy et donc
à la partager avec vous ouais on a
partagé 5000 euros chacun à la cité des
grèves à colombes
c'est ma première grossesse et la
réduction le savez que vous aviez fait 7
d'accord je suis pas sûr que la première
sur le savez donc ils m'ont l'anneau
prendre ce soir c'est ça donc
il faut parce que tu m'as dit non mais
ça arrive jean alain cacheux le dit non
mais c'est vrai la partie toi tu fais
partie de l'équipe de france
a tenu sa parole aussi ce
n'est pas ça
non mais
je suis d'accord mais alors non mais ça
c'est ça c'est une pour un vrai vrai
vrai risque c'est paraît-il qui lui
aurait le même impact dans cette saison
là voilà en tout cas ça devrait être
apte à être interdit par la prod nous
l'avons nous avons toléré la rumeur
court et moyen terme et comment ils vont
interdire non c'est à dire c'est ainsi
qu'un mec t'as sont revenus peu près là
les jeunes et à la star ac il y avait
elodie frégé la mine joviale avec michel
michel il a perdu à lui a donné le deuil
si demain tu as claude zidi voilà moi si
je gagne j'ai envie de donner la voix
lahej des dix ans quand même avec mes
potes ont fait ce qu'il veut non mais je
rêve c'est un deal
je trouve comme moi je ne suis pas au
courant en fait mais du coup
ça donne une valeur vraiment a ajouté au
programme moi je serai maintenant
parce que la star c'est pas pareil la
star s'était pas un jeu de stratégie
d'arrêt c'est vrai ça tu arrêtes tout le
monde est là en fait on sait pas que les
mecs soient ensemble of books ont manqué
les spectateurs et les téléspectateurs
encore une fois les candidats prennent
d'otages d'une action est ce que vous
l'avez vu sa balle et non mais justement
c'est ça le voir je pense à me dire que
j'aurais fait une saison entière et
qu'on s'est fait on s'est fait
arrêter les pactes toujours même mais
dans ces cas se renier mes pattes entre
les corps des décédés l'avancé de
l'émission
soumettre il se promettait de l'argent
s'ils étaient et dexter a bien sûr que
c'est un truc qui dit mais
qu'est ce qui vous a déjà promis de
l'argent à vous moi je me suis
jamais jamais déposé de l'argent
c'est bien de savoir que mathieu ne plus
jamais non non et non je serai
vraiment choquant ce qu'a dit momo c'est
vrai je vous aime beaucoup mais là les
téléspectateurs vont apprendre quand
c'est que le jeu est orienté parce que
quand vous faites un pacte évidemment
que ça oriente toute la saison à la télé
c'est à dire que quand vous votez pour
quelqu'un s'est orientée donc c'est
caché aux téléspectateurs donc moi je
suis je fais là c'est un vrai scoop
c'est pour ça aussi c'est énorme ce que
vous avez dit gilles en fait est ce que
vous prenez conscience de l'ampleur de
ce que vous avez dans l épave du
postulant gueule c'est vrai qu'il ya lui
et lens connaît bien c'est la famille de
mon frère mais agile en fait ce qui se
passe c'est que c'est ce que je vous dis
moi koh lanta c'est pas orientée vers
l'argent c'est à dire que nous quand on
sait qu'en latin on ne le fait pas pour
l'argent mais bon
c'est l'époque parce qu'on est générale
pour gagner un peu d'argent
sept jours il y aura du virage où était
inscrit non non pas du tout je veux moi
je trouve que je suis déçu en fait je
pense que ça va décevoir aussi les plus
jeunes c'est pas l'argent problème se
lasse pas tjoyas galactica qui parle
on voit des candidats dont on pense
qu'ils avaient soit seul soit en équipe
en fait ya des équipes secrets dont on
n'est pas au courant donc en fait la
lecture du problème elle est
complètement biaisé charlotte taussat
choc tulle à dire bah oui complet mais
je le savais mais oui tu l'a jamais dit
dans maxim on le sait pas assez de tact
no 3 est pas que moi je savais que ça
irait mais même sans ces discuter parce
qu'on lui a pas donné d'argent annonce à
16 ans est ce que tu viens de dire que
la cds droite ça va être un beau match
je sais qu'on va démarrer en juin non
mais je vous dis là ça va [ __ ] un
bordel cette affaire mais je ne vous
raconte même pas